pour parler de ces séries éliminatoires
exceptionnel on reçoit l'entraîneur chef
du canada montréal d'amener du chambon
soir dominique locale
merci d'être là ce soir c'est un gros
journée gros bilan mais je voulais pas
avoir ce soir annoncé une journée très
occupée
on arrive et cela parce qu'ils ont
entamée c'est quelque chose qu'on ne
passe à travailler à chaque année mais
il a été super et du oui ont finalement
de s'incliner comme ça mais on est fiers
dans le groupe ah oui les partisans
aussi était très très fier durant toute
la saison des séries dominées que j'ai
dit d'entrée de jeu est entraîneur par
intérim c'est une formalité on vous
allez nommé entraîneur chef ces quelques
jours j'imagine que je pense que marquez
et reposé la question des dossiers
réglés qu'est ce que ça signifie pour
vous parce que bon j'imagine que c'est
un rêve qu'elle caressait depuis
longtemps d'être l'entraîneur du
canadien de montréal
non surtout fait t2 de pouvoir accéder à
la ligue nationale c'est une chose de
pouvoir devenir entraîneur-chef dans la
ligue nationale mais c'est quelque chose
qui était un objectif pour moi c'est
certain mais de pouvoir le faire
les canadiens c'est encore plus spécial
aller a grandi en région ou tout près a
toujours été un partisan du canadien à
grande-synthe
moi je suis encore toute spéciale à
certains c'est vraiment de ça que je
veux parler ce soir pas vraiment de
stratégie doc et je vais laisser ça aux
sports c'est vraiment votre témoignage
qui m'intéressent on se connaît depuis
longtemps tous les deux originaires de
joliette
vous avez entraîné donc l'équipe locale
pendant des années donc série vraiment
extraordinaire les partisans qui ont
vibré comme jamais depuis 93 à quel
moment vous vous avez commencé
à savourer la saison cette année je sais
pas si j'ai eu face à bourg est certain
que si on est tellement ça va tellement
rapidement on a eu une saison qui tu es
tellement compliqué plein d'embûches
avec tout ce qui nous est arrivé
c'est certain que le parcours en séries
eux qui ont la pression on en a profité
à chaque moment mais je pense que ce
doit plus dans les prochains jours
prochaines semaines que nous sommes
capables de dépression je suis toujours
dit mais aussi apprécié terminer à
quelques victoires peines précieux
trophée ça apporte quoi comme comme
sentiments comme sensé sens que c'est
davantage de la fierté ou de la
déception de ne pas avoir pu aller
jusqu'au bout ce gros mélange les deux
parce que évidemment il ya de la fierté
parce qu'on on a fait un parcours qui
était assez incroyable
on a eu c'était s'était rempli
d'embûches qu'on ne passe à travers les
choses medelci pris en même temps si
loin et c'est une déception de ne pas
être capable de mettre la main ce
trophée lors qu'il ya beaucoup de gens
qui disent que si le trophée le plus
c'est la gagne au sport ou des sports
professionnels
et puis c'est quand tu arrives super est
de ne pas être capable de le terminer ce
trailer c'est quelque chose quand même
temps est décevant mais qui nous motive
à revenir la prochaine fois encore sa
dernière une autre occasion de l'est
pour son ouïe crèfcoeur est à la fois
une motivation d'aller jusqu'au bout une
prochaine fois je perds vu dans un cocon
texte assez difficile au sein du
canadien
vous avez pris la place de plongée alors
qu'il vous avait pris lui sous son aile
comme entraîneur adjoint
est-ce que ça a été difficile au plan
personnel cette année noës automates
ceci si j'avais écrit un script dans
lequel
mais entre 4,15 et c'est certainement
politique dans ses fonctions le devoir
partir de vos que partir en même temps
deux personnes que j'ai après kanak qui
m'ont beaucoup aidé quelques acquis
beaucoup d'expérience m'ont fait
confiance beaucoup qui me sont elles
aussi avec eux ça les voir participer
mais ça fait partie de notre sport
donc il va majorer mille fois dans notre
confiance mais c'est comme ça mais
aujourd'hui on perd on se prépare on
regarde en avant et plus on va être un
peu plus normale
c'est vrai que ça a été beaucoup
beaucoup de défis cette année avec la
bande émis puis la période d'isolement
aussi en raison de la coved dominique ça
y est extrêmement difficile à accepter
ça après avoir rêvé tant d'années de se
retrouver jusque-là d'être confiné comme
ça pendant deux semaines est-ce que vous
avez été découragés sans mal du courage
et c'est certain que j'ai tous les soirs
ont fait 14 ou en famille comme trois
mois par contre je sais bien à tours et
puis j'ai aussi réussi avec entraînement
avec les joueurs avaient pu garder le
même fonctionnement donc dans la
communication de loi à tous les jours
mais si des fois ce n'était pas
tellement non à tous les jours je
parlais au co entraîneur une ou deux
fois par jour mark webber je venais de
découvrir aussi les joies rentrer ce
sont des matches où après notre mail
petite a1 ou deux qui me plairait de
l'univers qui veulent que je revienne
des choses comme ça donc autant j'avais
peur de redonner au caire au moins j'ai
pu rester un petit peu connectés c'est
stressant quand même en d'avoir à gérer
l'équipe à distance de cette façon là
depuis la gare délimitera télé
troc et regarde un match du canadien
telus regard des menaces qu'il ne
pouvoir être capable d'avoir un impact
ou avec nous ou le seul match j'aimerais
qu'on regarde l'ensemble les hauts faits
d'armes en tant qu'entraîneur donc les
dates importantes vous êtes allé à les
facs vous avez remporté la coupe
memorial
ça veut remporter la médaille d'argent
plus à médaille d'or ensuite au
championnat mondial de hockey junior
avec le canada cette année finalistes de
la coupe stanley avec le canadien
quand on regarde ça en venant en fait
vous êtes devenu le premier québécois
développé par le canadien de montréal
est nommé dans la fonction d'entraîneur
par intérim mais bon ces mots là vont
certainement sans lever d'ici quelques
temps et comme les humains bergevin à
tout à l'heure
quelle est l'identité vous vous aimeriez
avoir pour l'équipe du canadien montréal
on parle vous courrez des québécois de
leur place au sein de l'équipe
et quel genre d'équipé vous voulez avoir
c'est certain que de ce côté là c'est
une des choses qui relèvent plus de
notre département des mains de marc et
compagnie ce que vous assurer qu'ils
travaillent fort à à trouver les
meilleurs jours parce que je suis
certainement considération le fait que
sammy québécois on peut le voir que
d'avoir cas présent on fait beaucoup de
joueurs j'en suis des joueurs qui mais
bon joueur qui nous avait aussi
éventuellement mais ce qu'on a vu comme
l'équipe 15 par le dit dans cette équipe
et c'est l'équipe comme on a vu à
travers les séries éliminatoires
l'équipe qui est il qu'ils travaillent
en équipe les réunions une équipe qui
est qui et compétition à chaque moment
qui a préparé à faire face à des défis
lankais a pas de joueurs qui sont
spéciaux des personnes qui sont
incapables de concevoir ça se mérite
une personne une équipe qu'on voit aux
excellents et félicitation encore une
fois pour la saison qui se termine
peut-être pas avec la coupe cette fois
mais avec beaucoup beaucoup d'espoir que
c'est possible de mes jambes
merci beaucoup d'avoir été là ce soir et
bonneval en avant